it's also true that Americans have
always accepted a degree of inequality
in equality of outcomes what seems to
have changed in recent years or at least
in people's perception of it is
something that the governor alluded to
which is that there seems to be growing
inequality of the starting place that
there's you as long as there was a sense
that okay some people are rich some
people are poor but at least I have a
chance I can pull myself for my
bootstraps I can work hard I can found a
company I can create something my
children's lives will be better than my
life as long as people had that sense
and also as long as they had the sense
that they were participating in a bigger
project you know that the words of the
Gettysburg Address you know that in the
Constitution it's on those are words
that belong to all of us we share we
don't share everything we have different
lifestyles but we all are part of the
system and we can be part of and we can
we can grow with it when people had that
sense when there was an economic growth
when they when they felt there was
upward mobility then people tolerate
inequality of some kind inequality as a
part of the human condition and people
accept it but it's a it's it's when that
begins to stop when people feel that
there isn't a chance when the starting
point isn't fair for everybody and when
there isn't a chance that it will be
fair or it isn't getting more fair and
this is when people begin to object and
this is the point that we're coming to
now the an is is right we tolerate
inequality when there's reasons for it
and when it doesn't have extraordinarily
harmful circumstances I think to to in
equality today is doing two things that
it didn't do at all times in American
history one you know the starting-point
argument I think is that is is something
that's been around for a long time but
it's gotten worse that people are
starting at a somewhat the social
mobility that the governor talked about
is is it lowest than it's been in a long
time but the other is and this is what
we ran was just talking about is the
loss of a common sense of belonging to a
single nation or a single project I mean
two books that came out a couple years
ago one from someone on the left and
ones on the right Charles Murray's
coming apart which really is about how
the richest ZIP codes in America and the
poor
of codes in America just completely have
a different language have a different
way of living don't talk about the
country in the same way and don't
experience the country in the same way
and they don't interact anymore and then
he says that's new that's not the way it
was before
and then George Packers book the
unwinding about the unwinding of a
common idea of an American dream I think
these two books in different ways but in
a similar way talk about the loss of a
common hopeful project that allows
inequality to be justified and I just
want to say one thing
um you quoted de Tocqueville right on
the Equality of conditions and I just
want to remind us that when de
Tocqueville is talking about the rise of
the Equality of conditions and the
Equality of conditions in America he's
talking about a 700 year
story which he tells right which goes
from the fact that we had a landed
aristocracy to the clergy and the
advantage of the clergy is that it was
open to everybody and then to the rise
of jurists again opened everybody the
Equality of condition that he's talking
about is not actually economic equality
he says one of the things that you note
about America is there's not misery like
there were in Europe but there's
inequality but what he says is the
Equality of condition is the Equality of
everyone feeling that they're equal as
equal Souls as equal in a democracy and
equal before the law which is why he
says that the the overriding core of the
spirit of American democracy great
democracy for him is dangerous right
because what democracy does is it takes
away the intermediate institutions of
our stock recei which protected people
from the tyranny of government and he
says democracy is happening it's a
providential fact that this can happen
in Europe and it's gonna happen America
equality is happening our worry is how
to protect ourselves from the danger of
equality and his answer that says what
the the the reason America was special
and the reason he went to America is
because what he calls the dogma of
popular sovereignty the dot the dogma of
of sovereignty of the people he says he
rises up out of the townships
it's that engagement in politics that
engagement that we
think we can come together and do things
together and control our world and let
me just tell you if you look at the
rights of women over the last 30 or 40
years in America I mean in the 70s my
own wife couldn't get a credit card
couldn't get in sure we have
dramatically through our women's
movement increased the rights of woman's
we have dramatically starting with the
civil rights movement finally realized
what the civil war was all about and
increased realized rights for African
Americans we have dramatically expanded
rights for gay people we have a much
more egalitarian society than we have
ever had in American history now that's
part of the problem because it is a
messy process
it seems divisive to some people
we now have a diverse nation and I would
argue diversity is a strength but there
are people in the society various levels
not just all wealthy people who find
this social change and it's happened
fairly quickly very threatening it is
not the America they thought if we go
back to old a wonderful cohesive America
of the 50s yeah when black people
couldn't vote Latinos mowed your lawn
you know you women couldn't get credit
cards they stayed at home that was a
great time not for most of those other
people so I think my view I I think the
country's way way better we still have
problems but I don't think it's in some
crisis before we get to the race
question and the race question obviously
intersects and overlaps with other
questions in American life the race
question the gender question the class
question but we began with the class
question and I want to go back to that I
agree that in many respects America is
you know there have been many advances
in terms of social equality on various
fronts but before we get to that I think
it's striking how often when we talk
about inequality in America there's the
focus on the 1% I view the shame of
American you know political economy is
the bottom not the top I mean that you
you use the word misery the United
States of America is a wealthy country
yet a quarter of youngsters in America
are in poverty
I mean impoverishment in America brings
social misery and there is not nearly
enough attention paid to that even the
crew III admire Barack Obama I'm a
supporter I admire him Barack Obama when
he's talking about redistributing income
in the United States does not talk about
the poor they talked the politicians all
of the politicians talk about the middle
class they do not what they sometimes
they make a mistake and talk about the
poor but the question of poverty and
what that means in America denied
obscured that it seems to me if we're
talking about political economy is where
our attention should be paid not the now
obviously everybody is going to be
implicated in that but it seems to me
that the the question of the
impoverished for a for a for a moment it
got attention in the 1960s for a moment
but now the problem of the impoverished
does not get nearly the attention that
it should get in the United States let's
add to the impoverished I know you care
about this too the imprisoned I mean
which is an enormous I mean we have a
higher population of imprisoned
population in this con our country than
any country any any industrialized
country in the world and the absence of
dealing with either poverty or the
imprisoned population and I think they
go together is I think shows an
inability to to think about that misery
people don't want to
talk about it I don't think there's a
good solution for it for a lot of people
not sure there's an example of the world
coming to an end there is a convergence
on the left and right about sentencing
changing sentencing guidelines and it's
and if our in Washington this is
happening state-by-state in Washington
if if the if it wasn't always I win you
lose
you could have there's a majority of
Republicans in Congress that would that
would have would call for a thorough
review of the sentencing guideline roll
off and the president has expressed
support but instead of engaging which is
the duty of the president in this
particular case he's using executive
authority to try to solve this problem
on the margins rather than deal with the
core issue I mean that's the that's what
we have to get back to is regular order
ways where when there is agreement you
pause and you take a deep breath and say
oh my god there's a there's a left-right
convergence let's deal with it now that
happens to your point that happens at
the local level more often than not it
certainly happens in state capitals it's
not happening in Washington and it
creates this deep disaffection the other
point I want to make is if we took all
of Warren Buffett's money and there's a
ton of it
50 billion or whatever he's worth and
the FBI came and expropriated every
asset that he owned all of them it
wouldn't change someone who was born in
poverty today
and so I the conversation needs to get
far deeper than saying like the the guy
or any know who he was there I'm sure
left wing the left-wing guy that
basically said effectively the rich guy
is the reason why people are poor well
maybe not maybe it's because the there's
an inequality of education in America
and there are people protecting the
status quo to make sure the economic
interests of the adults are taken care
of first rather than kids in poverty
gaining a quality education
maybe it's the inability to access the
first job which is true and we're
creating functional obsolescence for a
whole lot of people that don't have
skills usually you look at the
automation that's taking place today
it is not a joke to
if you're born poor in America today if
there's not a change in the path that
you're on that you will never get a job
and so these are issues that the
political system historically in our
country has been able to pause make
adjustments create the capacity for
people to deal with the current
challenges and we're not doing that now
and we're doing it at our peril
you mentioned the very first clip and I
think I think you're right
when you talk about when you put front
and center the race question so I want
to say something about the race question
and I want to link it with a number of
the personalities that have been
mentioned so there are three people who
have been mentioned a bunch of times
already
Lincoln Alexis de Tocqueville Thomas
Jefferson all three of them spoke a lot
and thought a lot about the race
question all three of them were
profoundly pessimistic all three of them
thought that the United States of
America would never be a multiracial
Society Lincoln through most of his life
was very interested in colonization
because he said over and over again nope
we're not going to have a society in
America where white people and black
people get along as neighbors and are
gonna be on an equal footing Alexis de
Tocqueville and democracy in America his
chapter the three races of America
profoundly pessimistic said no we're not
going to see racial democracy in America
Jefferson - again another person
interested in colonization so you know
these three very smart people thoroughly
pessimistic now there is another
tradition in American race thinking
there's an optimistic tradition the
great optimist of the 19th century was a
former slave the great Frederick
Douglass the great optimist of the 20th
century was Martin Luther King jr. in
there in the in our century in terms of
the race
question the most influential optimist
is the current President of the United
States Barack Obama now I know that you
and Barack Obama have your differences
but but one thing that you actually both
agree on is that there is a you know he
deeply believes that despite the history
of the United States and despite the
current problems that confront us and
the problems are deep we still live in a
pigment aa currency in the United States
in which the darker you are in the
United States the more you were at risk
of the bad things happening to you I
don't care if it's an incarceration
premature or death unemployment
what-have-you but even in the midst of
all that Barack Obama believes that we
shall overcome and I believe that too
but we are being really put to a tough
test and unfortunately there are people
who think we shall not overcome and
unfortunately it's not as if we can
sneer at them and think that they're
just you know being ridiculous
unfortunately the pessimists have reason
to be pessimistic